there in three beat weaves there and
thread the needle they've been there all
along whether you knew it or not
so there's a secret buried in many of
the most popular poetrics and this came
up recently during a private lesson that
I was teaching and I thought I would
share it with all of you Drex here from
Drex Factor POI sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and today I
want to delve into one of those great
secrets of the POI world that I don't
think we talked nearly often enough
about but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca becklinen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
all right so in order to show you what
this great secret is I'm going to have
to set up my home studio here so give me
just one second to do that
now I had a student a couple days ago
who was really struggling to learn how
to do a reverse three beat weave This Is
Not Unusual at all a lot of us even if
we've learned how to do a forwards three
beat weave we'll still sometimes
struggle with taking those same
instructions and making them work in
Reverse not the least of which because
when we switch into doing it reverse the
POI is always coming back at our face as
we're moving the POI around here and
that can feel a little bit scary so the
sticking point in the lesson was this I
was trying to get this student
comfortable with performing a reverse
two beat or Tic Tac that is moving the
POI back and forth from right to left
with the POI swinging in Reverse
direction that is going away from her on
the bottom and coming back towards her
at the top now whenever she would get
the POI spinning reverse and try to swap
which side of her body it was on this
would happen instead of switching the
POI back and forth across the front side
of her she would reach back behind her
because this involved spinning the point
in such a way that it felt like it was
going forward and that felt natural to
her body so what was going wrong here
was not actually that she wasn't
performing a two beat it's that she was
performing a two beat in the wrong
direction but wait what do I mean by
Direction here so to understand what was
going wrong here I want us to look at a
concept called a cross point so what
exactly is a cross point I'm so glad you
asked look how I am moving the POI back
and forth from the left to the right
side of my body there's a point at which
those two planes basically Collide out
in front of me as I'm bending the POI
back and forth between them if I turn up
the trails for a moment you'll see that
they're tracing out kind of an X shape
directly in front of me we call this a
Cross Point pretty cool huh let me show
you some more examples of them in action
see when we perform a two beat with both
hands involved we're actually creating
cross points for both of our hands the
POI are just going through them at
different points in time if I turn on
the trails once again you'll see that I
have two cross points directly in front
of me they're pretty close but not in
exactly the same spot and here's another
great example did you know that
windmills and corkscrews are both
technically two beat weaves in
themselves so check it out if I perform
a windmill I'm basically doing a two
beat weave that is happening in wall
plane instead of wheel plane that Cross
Point is actually hidden directly above
my head want me to prove it cool I'll go
ahead and bend over with this trick
taking it into a horizontal plane see
those cross points now and what a
coincidence now I've also just
transformed the move into a corkscrew
how about that and there's a ton of
other cross points hidden in other POI
tricks too for instance did you know
there's actually two cross points hidden
inside of a three beat weave let me show
you so the really obvious one of course
is the one that goes directly out in
front of us that looks just like what
we're used to seeing in a two beat right
but when we switch to a three beat weave
we're performing well a total of three
Beats
so where would that extra Cross Point be
located well it's a lot easier to spot
if I take one of my hands out of the
equation now do you see how I'm
performing two beats over on my left
hand side and only one bead over on my
right well the movement back and forth
between my left and my right side is the
Cross Point that we're used to saying
but something else is happening when I
perform this other beat over on my left
side and in fact if I really really
really exaggerate the movement out to
either side you'll see that another
Cross Point emerges right next to my
left shoulder this is actually happening
with both hands at the same time where
if I perform the full three beat weave I
wind up performing cross points both in
front of and over past my right shoulder
with my left hand and cross points out
in front of me as well as next to my
left shoulder with my right hand while
huh and believe it or not we're actually
also using cross points in moves like
thread the needle they may not be as
dramatic as the cross points that we see
in say a 3B weave or Corkscrew but
they're definitely there nonetheless we
can think of a thread the needle as
being moments when we're pushing our
hands and POI back and forth across two
parallel planes that are both in wall
plane directly in front of us when we
think of it through this lens we'll
start to notice that a Cross Point
emerges as we move our hands back and
forth they both happen to pass through
this Cross Point so wait a second then
could we say that cross points are in
play anytime the POI cross back and
forth across our body or indeed anytime
they cross back and forth across each
other why yes in fact we could I just
blew your mind right and that's why I
think it's actually kind of important to
drill cross points as their own discrete
concept so this is actually a drill I
really love giving to my beginner POI
students here's how it works you're
going to start off just performing a Tic
Tac going back and forth from right to
left side and back again across your
body in wheel plane and notice that in
doing that I'm pointing that Cross Point
directly out away from myself yeah cool
now we're going to go ahead and extend
our arm far away from ourselves as far
as it'll go and that's actually going to
shrink the two planes to being almost
right next to each other on either side
of our arm if we wanted to we could
maybe experiment with broadening how far
those planes are to either side and in
so doing make the Cross Point a little
bit more obvious but for right now just
having them work inside of this more
narrow range is going to be just fine
for us the reason being the next thing I
want us to do is I want us to bend our
elbow and aim the Cross Point directly
above ourselves the trick here is we're
taking this same orientation where we're
kind of pointing our hand out away and
that points the direction of the Cross
Point and moving it in a slightly
different direction so we get to go back
and forth between having the Cross Point
in front of us and directly above us we
want to repeat this same exercise but
out in wall plane going back and forth
in front of and behind us with the poi
extending our arms straight out and then
bending our elbow to point the Cross
Point directly up above ourselves when
we perform this exercise what we're
really learning how to do is decide
whether we're going to keep our planes
in wheel and aim that cross point out
away from ourselves
straight up or taking either of these
cross points over here into wall plane
directly above our cells or straight out
to the side it's our choice awesome so I
hope that I have managed to convey some
of the awesome potential there is inside
of learning how to direct your cross
points in different directions and the
ways that that can be useful throughout
your POI Journey so if these exercises
helped you out or you know of any other
ones please leave me a message and let
me know did you get anything out of this
video please leave a like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and to help my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible where
not for the kind support of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently a
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do so by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactor Ploy and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some of my other
beginner POI lessons I will include a
link to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up here on the
screen if you're watching on YouTube
also YouTube thinks that you might like
this top video here because it's been
popular amongst other viewers of my
channel so maybe give that a look as
well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace